foreign
producer James Senate uh NPR Stacy Smith
a writer for NPR has a full article
about a young lady uh paying off 18 000
worth of credit card debt not making a
lot of money as a journalism living in
Brooklyn and uh she did
this new craze that is sweeping the
nation apparently gen Z has uh has a
brand new fad out called
um cash stuffing it's a tick tock craze
living on cash
on the envelope system
it's called Cash stuffing such a New
Concept oh it's brand new just came out
the Tic Tac guys just figured it out and
so
um it's fun though I'm glad that I'm
glad she did it so she learned how to do
the envelope system we I I heard about
the envelope system uh 36 years ago the
first time from a guy named Larry
Burkett and it and I have a collection
of antique
envelope systems from the 30s the 20s
the 40s and the 50s it was quite the
thing there was little envelope systems
like Rachel Cruz's wallet had the red
wallet that we have in the store right
now all the colors but the brand new red
one also it has pockets in it that you
label with uh categories in your budget
and some things in your budget from the
very first day I started teaching this
Larry Burkett stole it from your
grandmother I stole it from Larry
Burkett and your grandmother we've been
teaching people to do um the envelope
system which now is called Cash stuffing
if you're a cool gen Z tic Tacker so um
that's how that works and so here's how
cash stuffing now that I know what you
call it here's how the envelope system
that we've taught for 40 years works
it's pretty simple you have some
categories in your budget
and they should be mostly if not all
categories of things you spend when you
are not
paying bills you're away from your desk
you're away from your home so a grocery
store
could be car gas
could be entertainment
budget it could be a restaurant budget
and I do recommend when you first start
your budget separate restaurants and
groceries because it'll make you realize
what you're spending on restaurants uh
and so what we taught people to do and
we still teach people to do this I just
didn't know it was cool again I mean if
you keep your clothes long enough they
come back just ask James I mean it's um
come back from the 90s right so um but
the uh
so the idea is I'm going to spend X
number of dollars for this pay period
on groceries I'll make up a number
500 bucks 400 bucks whatever the number
is you actually get that much cash out
of your paycheck and put the actual real
dollars into the envelope marked
groceries or in the Rachel Cruise
envelope system that and you label it
groceries and then you don't buy any
groceries except out of that envelope
and you don't buy anything out of that
envelope except groceries it makes you
keep your categories clean and true and
oh by the way when you uh are out of
money in that category
stop buying
and so this young lady goes to the
grocery store in this article with 46
dollars
in the grocery store forty six dollars
cash for the week uh apparently for the
month I no no it's for the week okay and
I believe
the article but I mean but she's like I
have to stay away from the fancy olive
oil aisle because I really you're you're
in for that stuff and I I'm not going to
get it and uh and she's buying day old
bread and gets a whole thing a loaf of
bread and she's like okay that's 20
slices that means I get 10 peanut butter
and jellies out of that and so you know
and she's going down two dollars and 36
Cents 80 cents six dollars and 38 cents
and as she's walking through she knows
she can't go over forty six dollars
because that's what's in her food
envelope well and it feels different
when you're spending Cold Hard Cash like
when you actually are handing over
something in that transaction that you
don't get back there's an emotional
attachment to it well you know the
Studies have shown uh and one of the
best studies I was done at MIT is they
were studying the the brain wave and
when you brainwave activity and when you
spend with real cash it activates the
pain centers of the brain when you spend
with plastic
nothing
no brain but um yeah but anyway no I
mean it's just dead there's no but
you're so in other words you have an
ouchy moment
when you spend cash because you have a
realization and you're right Rachel Cruz
pointed out years ago and I had never
thought of it but she and I were doing
an event together and she pointed out
when you hand you know you think about
when you were a kid if you wanted to
trade
one of your toys
to another kid for their toy so there's
a trade there's a transaction you give
them yours that you don't get it back
they give you theirs and so that's what
happens with cash we hand over president
faces and we leave with a loaf of bread
so there's a there's a transaction
there's a handy you give up something
and you leave with something
visually that doesn't happen when you
spin with plastic you give them the
plastic
they hand you the plastic back and the
loaf of bread
there's no transaction visually to your
point earlier and there's that sounds so
uh primitive but it activates those
parts of the brain and you have to
understand personal finance is 80
Behavior it's only 20 head knowledge so
when you put systems in place that help
you manage your behavior you are you you
you're it's a life hack you're you're
cutting you're cutting a corner and
making it work well that's part of you
know when people say I can keep credit
cards and I pay them off every month
they're I mean I'm not going to argue
with the people who say that they can do
that but do you spend more when you do
that do you not have that pain center go
off like if you were actually spending
cash would you be a little bit more
hesitant to buy that extra shirt to buy
that extra purchase that you maybe don't
need uh well studies prove that you
spend 12 to 18 percent more using
plastic than using cash I mean we've got
tons of research on this this is not a
new phenomenon and in in the digital
world we call it friction
the the easier it is without realizing
you spent money without too many steps
then boom you know you hit the PayPal
clean boom Oh Amazon you you click on
your card is already on file and you
just click Buy
and there's no I mean no recognition
that money's actually spent the weird
thing is is the studies also show that
when you use a debit card versus a
credit card
that there's more
physical physiological reaction
recognition I better have the money in
that account otherwise I just bounced a
check
when I use my debit card
right yeah otherwise I've just gone into
overdraft and there's a physical a
physiological recognition of that in
your body and in your brain versus when
you lay the plastic down you're just
like yeah we'll figure it out later
[Music]
quotation keeps getting even higher
because we've got we've got we've got
venmo where you can just transfer money
so easy you know friend's gonna be like
I'll pick up dinner and you can just
send the money we've got Amazon where
it's one click ordering it's like
everything it's getting so easy to spend
so it's like even even if you're using a
debit card I think it's getting more and
more important to create boundaries
around your spending so that you feel it
so that you know even if it's an easy
transaction there's a little bit of pain
or a little bit of boundaries to keep
you in line here's the other side of the
equation retired school teacher retired
Methodist Pastor
3.7 million net worth December of 2021
where debt free multi-millionaires
drowning in a cosmic ocean of Grace
giving is the most fun we can have not
involving fat sugar or chocolate
we're childless but we have 16 kids that
we support so we have 16 children
very cool see that's that's what happens
when you stuff catch